we have the curve y is equal to e to the
x over 2 plus X to the third power and
what we want to do is find the equation
of the tangent line to this curve at the
point x equals 1 and when X is equal to
1 y is going to be equal to e over 3
it's going to be e over 3 so let's try
to figure out the equation of the
tangent line to this curve at this point
I encourage you to pause this video and
try this on your own first well the
slope of the tangent line at this point
is the same thing as the derivative at
this point so let's try to find the
derivative of this and the value or
evaluate the derivative of this function
right over here at this point so to do
that first I'm going to rewrite it you
could use the quotient rule if you like
but I always forget the quotient rule
the product rule is much easier for me
to remember so I can rewrite this as Y
is equal to and I might as well color
code it is equal to e to the X x times 2
plus X to the 3rd to the negative 1
power and so the derivative of this so
let me write it here so Y prime is going
to be equal to the derivative of this
this this part of it e to the X so the
derivative of e to the X is just e to
the X so let me write that so we're
going to take the derivative of it and
that's what's amazing about e to the X
is that the derivative of e to the X is
just e to the x times this thing so
times 2 plus X to the 3rd to the
negative 1 and then to that we're going
to add this thing so not its derivative
anymore we're just going to add e to the
x times the derivative of this thing
times the derivative of this thing right
over here so we're going to apply we're
going to take the derivative so we can
do the chain rule it's going to be the
derivative of 2 plus x to the third to
the negative 1 power with respect to 2
plus X to the third times the derivative
of 2 plus X to the third with respect to
X
so this is going to be equal to negative
right this way
negative two plus X to the third to the
negative two power to the negative two
power and then we're going to multiply
that times the derivative of two plus X
to the third with respect to X well the
derivative of this with respect to X is
just 3x squared 3x 3x squared and of
course we could we could simplify this a
little bit we could simplify this a
little bit if we like but the whole
point of this is to actually find the
value of the derivative at this point so
let's let's evaluate let's evaluate Y
prime when X is equal to 1 y prime of 1
when X is equal to 1 this thing will
simplify to let's see this is going to
be e times e times 2 plus 1 to the
negative 1 power so that's just going to
be 1/3 right 2 plus 1 to the negative 1
so it's 3 to the negative 1 that's 1/3
so let me just times 1 3 plus E is to
the first power plus e to the first
power now let's see what does this do
this part right over here this is 2 plus
1 to the negative 2 power so this
actually let me don't want to I don't
want to so this part right over here is
going to be let's see this is going to
be or make a careless mistake here this
is 3 to the negative 2 power so 3
squared is 9 3 to the negative 2nd power
is 1/9 and so it's going to be 1/9 well
you're going to multiply this negative
there so it's negative 1/9 and then
we're going to multiply that times 3
times 1 so it's negative 1/9 times 3
times 3 right over here so it's negative
negative 3 ninths or negative 1/3 so x
times negative 1/3 and all I did here is
I substituted 1 for X and evaluated it
now this is interesting I have
essentially let me rewrite this this is
equal to e over three minus e over three
which is equal to zero so the slope of
the the derivative when X is equal to
one is zero or the slope of the tangent
line is equal to zero and so this is
actually pretty this is a pretty this
simplified to a pretty straightforward
situation if I wanted to write if I
wanted to write a line in slope
intercept form I could write it like
this y is equal to MX plus B where m is
the slope and B is the y-intercept now
we know that the slope of the tangent
line at this point it has a slope is
zero so this is going to be zero so this
whole term is going to be zero so it's
just going to have the form y is equal
to B this is just going to be a
horizontal line so what is a horizontal
line that contains this point right over
here well it contains the value Y is
equal to e over three so this is a
horizontal line it has the same y value
of the entire time so if it has about Y
value of e over three then we know that
the equation of the tangent line to this
curve at this point is going to be y is
equal to e over is equal to e over three
another way you could think about this
right over here is well let's substitute
what X is equal to one well there's not
even an X here but when X is when X is
any value Y is equal to e over three you
get B is equal to e over three or you'd
get Y is equal to e over three so it's
just a horizontal line so let's actually
visualize this just to make sure that
this actually makes sense let me get my
graphing calculator out get my graphing
calculator out and so I'm in graphing
mode if you wanted to if you wanted to
know how to get there you literally you
literally can just go to graph y equals
and I will do so e to the X power
divided by two plus X to the third power
X to the third power that looks right
and I
you set the range ahead of time to save
time so let me graph this so let's see
what what does all sorts of interesting
things all right oh look at that all
right so now we can trace to get to when
X is equal to 1 x equals 1 right over
there you see Y is equal to e over 3
which this is kind of its decimal
expansion right over here and it does
look like the slope right over here is 0
that the tangent line is just going to
be a horizontal line at that point so
that makes me feel pretty good about our
answer